girls that read the book why men love
now these girls slightly hate
them slightly he's trying to do better
these girls are the ones that men look
at and they're usually pretty but men
think too much of a headache that that's
because typically you're charging a high
price for low value a lot of these girls
either had no dad in the home a weak
father figure they typically think
they're better than what they are and
they typically want a man that like
doesn't exist so they have and they're
the type that say raise your standards
raise your standards don't accept this
this this this this without ever talking
about what they bring to the table